South Africa is mourning the deaths of
at least 74 people killed in a building
fire in central Johannesburg on Thursday
Witnesses say as many as 200 people
could have been living in the building
illegally
investigators are looking for the cause
the President says the accident is a
wake-up call to address the housing
crisis in South Africa's inner cities
let's go to famita Miller who's lie for
us in Johannesburg Familia do we know
more about what happened
more details have emerged since that
place started in the early hours of
Thursday morning and I'm just going to
step out of shop for a moment to give
you an idea of what it looks like now
and and describe exactly what people
went through as they tried to escape
that place many of them were trapped in
the basement area of this building and
what we also understand from City
officials is that there were a number of
shacks erected in the basement area and
it was densely populated partitioned off
and people were crammed into that area
and that's what made it very difficult
for them to escape I mean you can see
the debris and what the building looks
like and as we go further up it was more
difficult for people to try and Escape
because of the number of floors and
there was no way out of course safety
and issue very few safety regulations in
place because this was a hijacked
building it was illegally occupied now
we understand from reports and from
firefighters who are on the scene they
say that they found a number of bodies
piled up together behind a locked gate
behind a locked gate and people couldn't
get out because of that gate and this is
what caused many of the challenges in
trying to get out so it really paints a
devastating picture around what happened
and how Reliant people were on Emergency
Services but even when firefighters
entered they say that when they tried to
rescue people there were some who were
too scared to follow them through the
flames and so instead locked themselves
in their rooms and and this is why we
see that high number of people killed at
least 74. we know 12 of them were
children today officials have brought
sniffer dogs in to try and find any more
human remains and that's likely that
that death toll will rise
familiar it is such a harrowing story
and just looking at that blackened
building behind you and just trying to
imagine what people there must have been
going through the the fact that the
building was taken up or hijacked as you
said by homeless people does it speak to
wider problem in the city
it certainly does and we'll talk about
this building specifically first to give
you an idea of what the city is uh faced
with this building was condemned in 2020
and that means it should have been
demolished that wasn't done because
according to the NGO that were at least
this building or that occupied this
building they were confronted by slum
Lords who overran the building and then
brought in tenants and charged them
illegally to stay here in fact back then
about 140 people were arrested some of
them charged many of them illegal
immigrants so there are a couple of
issues the city is dealing with
management of the city some are calling
it dysfunctional and the hijacking of
buildings in that they're taken over by
slum Lords are there at least 400 of
them within Johannesburg that the city
can't do very much about there's also
the issue of illegal immigrants
undocumented uh foreigners who come into
the country and because there is a
housing crisis as you said earlier they
look for housing in places like this and
this is why they can be charged those
rental amounts by these slum Lords and
there's very little regulation because
this building was meant to have been
coerced condemned and meant to have been
top smallished it's remained unsafe
people moved in there was illegal
electricity connections and unsafe
electricity connections and water
connections so all these factors come
together resulting in the incident we
saw in the last 24 hours and the loss of
at least 74 lives
okay thank you for that for Mida Miller
there for us live in Johannesburg